the film bleeding-edge is about the  issue of forced organ harvesting in  China forced organ harvesting this issue  is about Chinese government  systematically taking organs from  prisoners of conscience and sell them  for profit for when transplant  yeah back in March I came here to  testify for the Conservative Party Human  Rights Commission on human rights in  China in general and back in June  I came here to testify on the issue of  organ harvesting the same Commission so  after that mr. John Buerkle invited me  to screen this film in his house  in Westminster  well I met Miss World Canada 2013 as any  action gem during a human rights  conference and she was speaking about  the forced organ harvesting issue in  China and I was incredibly inspired at  that time I was 16 and 10 years after  now I'm Miss World Canada and I decide  to use this platform to make real impact